Welcome back everyone
Marvel just revealed a bunch
more deleted scenes from Spider-Man
No Way Home, including Tom Holland,
in several versions of the symbiote suit.
There are a ton of Easter Eggs.
Even Spider-Man PS4 was supposed to be in
that movie at some point in a live action
in a more legit comic book
accurate version of the iron Spider suit.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
Ahsoka episodes are starting really soon.
I'll be doing videos for that.
The Loki. Season
two episodes are coming after that.
I just did a new trailer video for it,
so I had a link for it at the end of this,
down in the description below.
So there's a lot of big stuff coming up,
Least of all Spider-Man
four with Tom Holland.
But recently
you probably saw on your feeds
all these new deleted scenes
Marvel was releasing for Spider-Man.
No Way Home, all way crazier
than the actual deleted scenes
that they released with the Blu ray.
All the coolest months
They never wind up releasing.
For some reason, just starting
with the biggest one Spider-Man
in multiple versions of the full
on symbiote suit from the comics.
All Spider-Man symbols are made
in the style of the classic comic
book symbiote suit style.
Like his Spider-Man symbol, changes
between his previous version
in the movie
to be more comic book accurate.
When he first got the symbiote suit
during the original Secret Wars Comics.
Well, I mean, you look at that
at the obvious comic connotations
between Venom and Spider-Man,
and it is it's inherent.
So. So the minute Sony made their Venom
movie and it worked as well as it did,
and Tom Hardy became as iconic
as he has become as Venom,
then the obvious questions and how do we
how do we start to to to merge them?
the first version, the logo is gold
colored, then there's a red one
in a traditional white one,
which would have been the most comic
book accurate to the version
he wore in the comics after Secret Wars.
The red one is also a super deep cut.
There's a cool story behind that Red
Spider-Man's symbiote Suit logo.
that, before the original Marvel's
Secret Wars event happened in the comics,
like when they were still planning it,
they ran a fan
contest to redesign Spider-Man.
So a bunch of fans
submitted their artwork.
So in 1982, Randy Schuler of fans
submitted his Art of Spider-Man
wearing a black suit
with a red logo like they hadn't come up
with the concept of the symbiote yet.
that didn't become an actual thing
until Todd McFarlane did the Venom comic.
It was a bit of a retcon.
They turned it into the symbiote suit.
When he got the suit in secret wards,
they just called it
the quote unquote alien costume.
Like the whole term. Symbiote
didn't come till much, much later.
So when the fan was submitting his design
for this with the red logo,
he just thought it would be cool
if Spider-Man wore a black costume
Ultimately, Marvel decided
to take his design and change it
a little bit to the White logo version.
But he gets credit basically
for coming up with the idea of Spider-Man
wearing the black costume
Recently, Marvel actually
brought that back into Canon with Peter,
David and Rick Leonard when they did
sensational Spider-Man self-improvement
with some Easter eggs for him, actually
getting the original suit in secret wars.
Like they brought a little bit of that
story back during the original version
of events, Spider-Man's suit gets damaged
during secret wars and he finds
this alien device technology
which replaces it with this symbiote suit.
But at the time
it was just an alien costume.
no. In the deleted scenes,
the white logo is self-explanatory.
Like they wanted to do a symbiote suit
with the Secret Wars Easter Egg,
but make it more accurate to those comics
The gold logo was then trying to do that
symbiote suit,
but say that it was a combination of them
getting the Venom
symbiote while he was wearing his newest
advanced suit from the end of the movie,
which itself was a combination
of the Steve
Ditko advanced suit in the iron spider
suit with the gold highlights They didn't
say exactly when he was going to get
this Venom symbiote suit in the movie.
But if you remember that originally Venom
wasn't supposed to
just be relegated to a post-credits scene,
during the theatrical cut.
They did the Venom
symbiote post-credits scene with him
leaving behind a piece of the symbiote.
But originally they were going to have
Venom show up earlier
in the movie and actually fight
with Spider-Man at the Statue of Liberty.
Final battle against the other Sinister
Six villains.
That's what Tom Hardy's
dialog was meant to be, a reference to.
Originally
he was going to Portland, to New York City
and meet Spider-Man that way.
it sounds like their alternate plan
was for Venom to show up just in case
Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield
didn't work out for some reason.
So there were multiple versions
of the end of the movie
when they were supposed to all show up,
and in one of them,
venom comes instead of them.
it sounds like at some point
during that fight, Spider-Man
would have gotten the Venom symbiote
and then it forms the suit around him.
And that's how they explained the logo
this was a whole big thing.
When the first Venom solo movie came out
with Tom Hardy, like, how are they going
to explain the logo if he hasn't met
Tom Holland's Spider-Man yet?
But now he kind of has.
Like he's seen him on screen,
so he knows what the logo looks like.
Kevin.
Foggy had been saying for a long time
that there was a chance
that they would actually cross over,
but he didn't say which movie
that would happen
or how they were going
to make that go down.
it sounds like for a long time
they were planning on that
being Spider-Man No Way Home until Tobey
Maguire and Andrew Garfield worked out.
they didn't say what the new version
of the Post-Credits scene would have been
had Venom shown up earlier and done
the symbiote suit twist, I'm assuming
it would have been something similar
where he still gets
Portal back to his universe
at the end of the movie,
but leaves behind a piece of the symbiote
so that they can continue on
with the much bigger
Spider-Man symbiote saga in the future
like they're doing right now. But.
They would have changed some of his dialog
so that instead of just yelling
about Thanos and the five year
time jump getting drunk,
he would have also been
yelling about their fight
with the Sinister Six villains.
seeing the movie, it seems pretty obvious
why they cut this Venom
symbiote scene from it.
First they got Tobey Maguire
and Andrew Garfield. No problem.
So the movie was already
too full of characters to have Venom
show up during the final battle,
and they just decided to cut him out.
since he wasn't there,
it wouldn't have made sense
for Tom Holland to get the symbiote
before the end of the movie in Marvel play
just decided early on because of all that
they save
the symbiote suit twist for Avengers
six secret wars
so that they could do
a much more comic book accurate
version of him getting the symbiote suit
The whole idea in Spider-Man's appearance
is that
every time he shows up in a new movie,
he gets a new suit
and they really want to reach
for deep cuts for Avengers movies.
So why not have one of the biggest deep
cuts of all time?
First, Secret Wars.
the second big deleted scene
seems even crazier than the Symbiotes,
if you can believe it.
Spider-Man PS4 apparently showing up
during that final battle, meaning
he would have been a live action version
of the character canonized to the MCU.
There are a couple of things
that might have been going on here.
He might have been a substitution
for Tobey Maguire or Andrew Garfield
if they had dropped out of the movie
at some point
or they didn't work out for some reason.
we know there were multiple versions
of the final battle
with a bunch of different combinations
of characters fighting in the scene
or this might have been Tom Holland's
Spider-Man, just getting a new suit
before the final battle
the way he did in the movie.
But this one just happens to look exactly
like Spider-Man PS4 suit
Like the scene where his advanced
suit combines with the iron spider nanites
to create his new suit Might have just
turned into this PS4 looking suit.
I literally just did a trailer
for Spider-Man
two with that version of the character,
so I'll post the link in the description.
They're kind of in the middle of doing
their own version of the symbiote saga,
but it's based on the plot
from the first Spider-Man PS4 game.
So it's not like the comic book symbiote
saga The hell is going on with me?
He's not himself. Go help him.
they pretty much already canonize
Spider-Man
four in Miles Morales from that universe
into across the Spider-Verse, though.
But they were the animated versions
of the characters.
most of you remember,
they did have a bunch of live action
crossover scenes with animation in Across
the Spider-Verse with Tobey Maguire,
Andrew Garfield, Tom Holland in Venom.
So expect more live action
versions of the characters
to appear in Spider-Man
beyond the Spider-Verse.
the next big deleted scene was a much
more comic book accurate iron spider suit.
And this would have been the suit created
from that combination of the advanced suit
in the Infinity War Iron spider suit.
The final version they went with in
the movie
was more of a blend of the red
and black colors.
This one would have been a much bigger
change, looks super cool.
Maybe at some point
they'll do some kind of version of this.
Usually Marvel does that.
Like they'll have really cool
deleted scenes, a really cool concept,
or they just won't work out
for some reason or other pull back on it.
They'll bring it back around
in some future movie
There are a bunch of other smaller deleted
scenes and concepts that they revealed,
mostly more comic book accurate designs
for everybody in the movie.
Like a more comic book
accurate version of Doctor Octopus.
There was also an iron fanny pack.
Spider-Man used to hold his iron
spider suit.
It was meant to be his version
of Iron Man's briefcase Armor.
The Iron Man.
Mark buy from Iron Man two,
but a fanny pack.
something about this
just makes it feel like Ned
and MJ would have clowned on it
pretty hard during the movie.
there was also an Iron Man style
belt that he wore that did
basically the same thing,
but just feels a little more sleek.
there were tons of other
big deleted scenes and Easter eggs.
I just did a video for like Ned leads
turning into a version of Hobgoblin
Green Goblin getting an Iron Man suit
that he turns into an Iron Goblin suit,
I'll post links for all that stuff
down in the description below.
Andrew Garfield
was also recently talking about the future
of his Amazing Spider-Man two,
saying that they envisioned
he would go on to continue
being Spider-Man in his universe,
having all kinds of adventures, Could you,
would you do it again?
Do you would you put the suit on
if given the opportunity?
you know, never say never.
I mean, it's such it's a character
that's always going to be so meaningful
to me and so beautiful to me.
And again, it comes back to service.
You know, I think
if there's a way, because that's what
that's what that character is all about.
He's all about serving the greater good
and serving his fellow
fellow people, his fellow, you know,
serving humanity and all life, you know.
So if there's a way for me to
continue to add to the legacy
of that character in a way that feels
like it's of service
to an audience, of service,
to the themes that,
you know, the themes that Stanley kind of,
you know, injected that character with.
I'm open
and of course, I'm very, very open.
The whole idea
with his Amazing Spider-Man is it had
they made The Amazing Spider-Man
three, they would have started him
on his own Venom symbiote saga
introducing a bunch of other characters
that they're now doing in present day.
Like Morbius, for instance,
is more Ben Time,
a full Sinister
six trilogy of spin off movies,
which they're still trying to do
right now.
Let me know in the comments, though,
when do you want them to do Spider-Man's
symbiote suit
if they don't do a full symbiote saga
starting in Tom Holland's Spider-Man four,
they might save that for further on
to click here for my new Loki
Season two trailer video and click here
for all those other big Spider-Man
deleted scenes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!